me
rg 2
皆様
明けまして
おめでとうございます
2017年初め出をです私は
2017年どうこう言う場合にいい
一つ
やらなければいけないことがあります去年2016年1月13日
私は動画で
こう言いました
お菓子は止めません
ファー
バッハ
それから月日は流れ約1年350日ほどが経過しました
お菓子が
食べれるようになりました
私はあのヒット通り2016年はおかしい10選一つも食べませんでした
つらかったよ暗かったよ僕のチャンネルすっごい昔の動画から見たことある人なら
わかると思うんですけども本当に食器はおかしいの商品紹介をしていました
ぷっ
今となっては信じられないんですよコンビニで働いて何で新商品が出たらすぐわかるん
でお菓子の情報を誰よりも早く取り入れてたんで挑戦紹介のプロだったんですよ
ちょっとよくわかんおかずの商品紹介するぐらいぷ笑顔でお菓子食べながらマンチ
youtube やってた男が2016年去年に関してはお菓子を食べることすらもし
ない別名を送ってたわけですよどう思いますこの現実をオレにとって非常に苦しい1年
だった
あそうだあの母ちゃんから何か届いてたんだった人ってきます私はほぼ今年実感
られなかったんですけどちょっとかあさんから贈り物が届いてるだけてみます
何何えなにこれ
んだっ
なんかすごいこんなの入ってたんですけど明けましておめでとうございます皆さんで
食べてくださいむしろに注意
+
yeah
ちょっとまじか分部を頭ですけどうーん
母ちゃんこれはスプーンを買った家さんこの量はやばいよ
てございましたこっちもん
だあの準備なすっゴリゴリ重税案はすごいなあこれは何もうこれは何
お節料理を送ってくれたので何も完全お節料理じゃんというわけで母ちゃんからおせち
料理が届きましたはいすごいなあああもう多いだの好きなのしか入ってないよ
全部お菓子じゃないですか母ちゃーんでもおかしいじゃないか母ちゃん5名
自分でも買ってきちゃったもらえると思ってなかったらすべてめっちゃすっては妻と
いうわけでみなさんごらんの通りなんですけど
5の僕のことを自省にしかしないかーちゃんがこれだけ気を使ってくれべくらい実は
辛い1年でございましたまずそもそもなんでお菓子お金家にしたかっていう話になるん
ですけど
禁止にした理由あれば体の健康を気遣って
1日3食全部を化する時とか普通にあったんでそれぞれお菓子が大好きで
さすがの親も心配してくれてちょっと動かして食べ的じゃないっていう話になって
お菓子を禁止してたんですけどもおかげさまで体はかなり健康だったと思います厳しい
スケジュールの中でもねなんとかやっていけたんでお菓子食べてるかマシなものを食べ
てたのかなって思ったんですけども
やっぱね
体は健康でも心が健康じゃなかったです
今の名言ですよあのそうなんかでいいんですけどやっぱを風美味しいですよ
お菓子って何がすごいかっていうとやっぱり食べるとね心が幸せになります心が健康心
がしあわせになる改めておかしいの大切さに気づかされた1年だったと思います
間口なんとか1年間乗り越えてようやくここまで来ましたかという話でございますがん
なんだこれ
本当に昔がないと気遣ったよ
で待ってミスタードーナツを食べるやんけ編集中に食べるっとお菓子が無いのが本ずつ
なかったオイラーの心の支えがないと言っても過言ではなかったから長者さんが皆さん
でもいろんな人に頑張れ頑張れって言っていただいて
最初の12ヶ月は本当に遊学島の戦いだったんですけどその12ヶ月さえ我慢できれば
意外とサラッといきましたけどまあまあにすぐに食べたくなる時がありました
もう
そこはきれいでこれでしかなかったので本当に僕あの2016年を通して精神力が
かなりついたと思います
忍耐力が我慢することの大切さ人間的に一つステップアップできたのじゃないかなと
思います
350日ぶりに箸を食べてみようと思います
緊張するなあのなんかも罪悪となるんですよ
1年くらい食べてないとお菓子買うことに代役があってすっごい
機を撮りました買うときは勝ってください恫喝に到底したねかわかんないやばいなぁ
プレイも食べていいんでしょ完全復活だよこれあったからかな送り
エンティティが完全に止まってた去年は r は甘いもの食って脳がハッピーになると
僕は普段の力を解放できるのでまぁ2017年は食べ過ぎないように動かしをたくさん
食べようと思います愛情に何食べると思いますかちなみにもう決まってますもう絶対
これだと思ってました
カントリーマアムのパティラーズです格別だいすきってわけでもないんですけどもこれ
すごい好きで
リーダーは全部好きだよあ全部好きだけどもこれからまずは始めようかなと思います
わー
良いよ空のかでは皆様2.0長年も何卒よろしくお願い致します
例えば
いただきますん
あーやばいやばいやばいやばいまず緊張してきたすっごい悪いことしてる気がしちゃう
んだけど
いやー悪いことしてません新たな1年のスタートです
乾杯
me
ああそうずっと本当に食べていいよう
ああ
ああああ思い出すなぁこれがおか歯科
久々すぎてリアクションが取れで堂々違反すればいいんだ
わー
うまい綾部安全に力がみなぎってくる按分だったパワーが今フルパワーになってる
くらいの勢いですコーラ本ですよねえもう完全に俺の前なこんなのと見合ったよ
me
ああああああああ
綾部これがコーラカーバーはオランジーナさんちょっとちょい
[音楽]
あー尊い
某もうふわぁ
じゃぁぁぁ
うわぁモー娘ピザポテトはいというゲー350日簡便にお菓子を食べてみたところ結果
re
頭とかったです何かを我慢する力というのはとても大切です
僕は一年間お菓子を食べれないという条件と機会に強靭な体力と眠剤力そして開放感を
得ることができました
うんあっはぁ今年の俺は
[音楽]
今何個か食べたんですけどめっちゃ気もツール
体質が変わったのかなお菓子食べるって気持ちだけなんですけどすっごい共助0
[音楽]
ん
こら産めな